A man in Portland calls the police about a break-in from the house that he broke into.
That is a story tailor-made for John Berman.
The bad guys from Home Alone weren't particularly good at their jobs.
But the worst criminal ever?
Maybe, the guy who broke into this house in Portland, Oregon on Monday.
911?
I just broke into a house...
...and the owners came home.
You broke into a house?
Yeah.
See? The operator didn't believe it either.
25 - year - old Timothy Chapek allegedly broke in to take a shower.
When he heard the owner come home, he got scared...
...and yes, called 911.
They can hear me.
In the middle of this 911 call, you can hear owner, Hillary McKenzie, confronts him.
Why are you in my house taking a shower?